[Musique]
ne dites plus pas sanitaire mais parce
vaccinale les députés ont voté
définitivement le texte hier soir le
pacs wass vacin le pass vaccinale
devraient entrer en vigueur à la fin de
la semaine selon nous espérons que d'ici
la fin de la semaine le conseil
conscient elle se soit prononcé et que
le président puisse promulguer ce texte
un texte profondément contraire à tous
les principes républicains qui va selon
le mot du président de la république
emmerder tous les français mais 90% de
vacciner on n'a jamais autant de cas
c'est à dire plusieurs centaines de
milliers de cas par jour dans notre pays
donc le pass matinale est inutile et je
déplore que le gouvernement ait
abandonné l'idée de gérer cette crise
avec raison c'est peut-être via
l'analyse de nos eaux usées que nous
viendrait la bonne nouvelle la possible
fin de la vague omicron dans les eaux
usées on a de moins en moins de virus et
les courbes épidémiques sont même tout
en train de plonger au royaume uni en
une semaine on apprend des cas ont été
divisés par deux pour dire à quel point
cette chute va être brutal scénario du
pire s'éloigne la dcri a commencé le pic
des infections en tout cas a été passé
ces jours ci cette décrue apparaît déjà
dans les chiffres des réanimations la
barre des 4000 personnes en soins
critiques n'aura pas été franchie les
chiffres sont en baisse depuis trois
jours le nombre d'infections va
décroître considérablement pendant le
mois de février est effectivement au
mois de mars on devrait être à des
niveaux très bas ce calendrier de passes
vaccinale va vraiment problématique
parce que ça va baisser très vite au
bout d'un moment qu'on aura plus de cas
et que les services se serait un petit
peu vide et probablement autour du 15
février j'entends
et pas d'exception pour les sportifs
qu'il ya d'ailleurs une exception pour
personne et donc couru les sportifs
doivent se vacciner et le pass vaccinale
vaut pour tout le monde donc pas de
novak djokovic à roland garros en mai
prochain tant qu'il ya de max ophuls
vacciner sursis sur l'accident qui a pas
de vaccin pour espérer une nouvelle
condamnation pour eric zemmour 10000
euros d'amendé pour provocation à la
haine en septembre 2020 sur ces news il
avait qualifié les migrants mineurs iso
et de voleur assassin et violeur vous
saviez que certains joueurs de l'équipe
de france n'étaient pas vaccinés
honnêtement
ça peut arriver ça correspond proportion
de la population qui ne le fait pas mais
bon j'imagine qu'ils vont le faire oui
vous allez vous leur demandez
j'ai un agenda judiciaire chargé car on
veut me diaboliser on veut par la
justice me faire taire parce que je suis
le seul candidat à l'élection
présidentielle a posé cette question
majeure de l'immigration de l'identité
de la france et du grand remplacement
côté un peu lourdingue péché chez lui et
je le dis avec respect à vouloir
polémiquer sur tout
même le handicap est un sujet polémique
donc c'est un peu lourdingue web celle
qui occupe 70% de la planète la mère
du fond du fond enfin le fond des océans
là puisque le hong haeran ce qu'on a
entendu les passes et les danses
convient à l'été du discours ambiant
bonne que qu'il ait une certaine
éloquence il n'y a aucun doute là dessus
il en joue d'ailleurs et soudain la voix
si ceux ci produit de la science
produits de l'intelligence humaine
incroyable
au delà de tous les biotopes voici
l'espace infini j'ai donc vu que c'est
effectivement un meeting qui coûtait
excessivement cher à one man show et je
suis moi plutôt pour redonner le pouvoir
au peuple et pas pour incarner un homme
providentiel donc c'est très c'est très
intéressant de voir comment jean luc
mélenchon qui est si critique avec la
terre entière sur n'importe quel sujet
est capable de faire ce genre de chose
dont je suis certain les critiquerai
énormément si ça n'était pas lui même si
l'ambiance glauque que j'aurais agi avec
autant de champions